je rejoins ma collègue viviane mal et
que vous a dit tout à l'heure que vous
avez répondu effectivement c'est très
riche comme entretien simplement et il
ya quand même un sujet sur lequel je
vous ai pas trop entendu alors je suis
sénatrice de la guyane donc je vais
adresse principalement à la fédération
des entreprises de recyclage vous le
savez la guyane est confronté à un gros
problème d'élimination des vh eu un
certain moment on avait même évoqué
quelques 15 me lever à chaud dans la
nature donc j'ai deux questions pouvez
vous me dire quelles sont vos relations
avec l'association pour le recyclage des
déchets automobiles en guyane et quelles
sont les mesures à prendre pour
accélérer le traitement des vh eu parce
que lorsque les mères procède à des
compagnes de
ramassage de vih et dans les quartiers
bas trois jours après ses vertus sont
remplacés par d'autres versions et en
fait on voit pas le bout du rouleau et
et c'est une problématique en tout cas
qui touche toutes les communes sauf bien
sûr les communes de l'intérieur qui sont
clavé et bien souvent qu'il n'ya pas de
vêtements il ils ont cas particulier des
véhicules hors d'usagé enregistrons dans
quelques minutes faire un peu de
pédagogie la première étape c'est
finalement d'aller chercher la voiture
jusqu'à maintenant le dispositif
national ne prévoyez pas
la collector qu'aujourd'hui il ya une
reprise gratuite en centre vh eu cercle
c'est le dernier détenteur qui amène la
voiture avec la loi qui ment résilience
la chose a changé c'est que maintenant
c'est un d un produit départ donc ça
veut dire que les constructeurs vont
devoir financer cette partie là après ça
toute la chaîne elle est complètement
différente cette filière elle vit sur
l'horaire la pièce de réemploi donc ça
veut dire qu'il faut qu'il ya un marché
de l'isr emploi si ce marché n'existent
pas en local bah c'est une recette
considérable qui en moins donc ça veut
dire que ça veut dire que le soutien
financier qui devrait être apportée par
l'arep sera beaucoup plus important dans
les îles après ça il ya la dépollution
qui est la première chose à faire il
faut dépolluer la voiture et après ça
effectivement la logique voudrait on
n'aura pas de quoi financer je pense des
broyeurs mais il faudra moins pressés
partir de là il faut que les voitures
sont dépollués près c'est qu'on a
prélevé les quelques pièces qu un
intérêt bah voilà cimetière là pour le
coup c'est des bateaux entre guillemets
sans danger qu'on peut qu'on peut
affrétés